Hey look guys my name is trying to
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we planned an event system for
hazel
if you haven't seen that video make sure
that you check it out I know it's
planning video I know you might think
that it's kind of boring and it's let's
just rice and curd sure but it's really
important to understand why we're making
these kind of architectural decisions
that we actually are making because we
don't understand that then well you're
not gonna be able to learn how to
actually write a game engine which is
what the series is all about so
definitely make sure you check that out
the second thing is I want to you just
give a huge thank you to all the patrons
that make this series possible if you
guys aren't supporting the series you
can go to pattern icon for safe the
Cherno you'll get episodes like a week
early as well as access to the source
code of the hazel engine as fast as I
can ride it so I mean I mean we've
already got like a window and like
colors on the screen and all that stuff
already working correctly kind of in
that development branch so if you want
to kind of just surge ahead or see where
this is heading or just you know get
some gear hands on actual code that is
way more kind of further along than what
we're actually doing in these videos
that's definitely best players to do
that so speaking of which because we're
kind of getting into large systems I
thought that I would kind of change the
format of this series a little bit and
this is kind of the first episode in
which we kind of see this this this
change that is happening so in previous
episodes what I would do is I'd kind of
just write code in front of you and I
and I still will do that to an extent
but that part is actually going to
change because this event system is a
considerable amount of code and these
videos which I originally wanted to keep
between kind of ten to fifteen to twenty
minutes are kind of becoming twenty to
thirty minutes and I mean even thirty
plus some episodes which is a little bit
too much I want this series to be a
little bit more accessible a little bit
more consumable and I guess more so
about the actual decisions and how the
code works rather than actually
physically writing out the code in front
of you now I might I might make a video
on why I made this decision and we can
talk about it maybe in another video I
don't want to really just
we were in this event video by talking
about all that kind of stuff but what's
going to change now and probably going
forward is that instead what I've done
is I've taken code from that private
development branch code that I've
already written code that I've already
tested code that I've been probably
using for a while at this point and I've
kind of merged it into this hazel public
repository and then what I'm going to
effectively do is explain how all of it
works of course and also kind of go
through the diff of before and after the
last episode now because this is pushed
to github you can actually look at the
differential if you want to once this
video goes public but even in the video
I'll kind of go through each change and
explain what's actually happened and not
just kind of why I've done this but also
how it works so I think that ultimately
I mean in terms of learning it should be
exactly the same it's just gonna save a
lot of me typing out stuff that doesn't
necessarily need to be typed out in
front of you and I can't even talk about
some of the reasons why like some of the
different different things that I
thought about while writing this code as
well because this code is all 100 Center
in by me
so of course I know exactly why I've
decided to do certain things and not
other things anyway without further ado
let's just jump in and take a look at
this event system although also I have a
few amendments from the premake video I
believe that will also cover here but
hopefully this new format is also kind
of entertaining for you guys to watch as
well I think it actually might be easier
to watch because instead of just waiting
for you to write a code it's more more
of the episode is spent on me actually
explaining the code and talking about
the actual code rather than physically
talking about so anyway let's just jump
in and take a look so here is the event
a file I'll kind of go through what I've
actually added so that you guys can see
essentially what I've done is I've
created this folder called events inside
the hazal directory and there's four
files in here there's the event dot H
header file which is kind of the main
file for this whole event system and
then we've got different types of events
kind of split up into their own files so
we'll kind of go through how these work
first and then we'll take a look at an
example of actually creating an event
just to see what the API kind of looks
like and what we can actually do with it
okay so let's start with the with the
top I guess this file is completely new
so there's no need to show like a div or
anything because it's 100% new
so the first thing I want to kind of
talk
of these includes because these are
something that I really don't like
including into files like this because
string and also functional I just kind
of C++ standard library stuff that first
of all should really probably be in a
pre-compiled header but even above that
they should just be kind of included
maybe in core so one thing that we need
to get to doing very very quickly
because it's just gonna be the further
along this engine gets the harder is
committing it to integrate later is
precompiled headers so we might take a
look at that maybe in the next episode
or sometime soon in the future okay so
I've written a nice little comment here
just to explain how the event system
currently works and basically this just
says that it's blocking right which
means that the way that this is designed
right now is that it's not buffered it's
not kind of events aren't deferred as
soon as they actually happen like as
soon as the mouse is clicked that's it
the whole application basically stops
and then processes that event it's not
kind of just like let's get the
information from the event push it into
some kind of queue or some kind of
buffer and they kind of defer until
until we actually go through the event
you know pass or whatever and all kind
of even propagate it through like some
kind of event bus or something no it
just happens immediately so this is just
a little comment explaining that how the
design currently works and maybe in the
future we can buffer them into some kind
of event bus okay cool
so this is kind of the heart of
everything so we have this event class
but we also have an enum which basically
an ATM class which describes the event
type right so we have different kind of
event types I've kind of split them up
into separate lines some of them we
might not even use we can explore using
them for example these ones I'm not a
hundred percent convinced that I
actually want to use but everything else
is totally fine and you can also see
that because this code is is code that
I've already written and because it's
kind of written in the hazel development
branch I'm able to actually like I
totally forgot about Mouse scrolling for
example and if I made this video I might
have just forgotten about that that I
had to add it later but because I've
kind of gone through and been using his
code for a while it's kind of matured I
guess to the point where the code that I
can merge in here and show you guys is
actually somewhat you know final I mean
obviously will tweak it in the future as
need be but it's a little bit more
mature than me just kind of writing
what's off the top of my head or bed
on some loose design that hasn't been
through like you know actually usage
like this card has because I've been
using this code quite a bit in that
hazel development branch anyway so we
have different kinds of event types
we've got all the window events now
these actual events are implemented in
their relevant kind of files so
application event kind of covers all of
these key events covers key pressed and
released and then Mouse events cover all
this stuff so protected look at
application event for example you can
see we have that like window resize
event I don't think about yeah okay app
Brenda app update app tick window close
and all that stuff it's all kind of
implemented here and we'll take a look
at that later
so this in arm basically is just like
hey you know what is we have a code
assigned to each event you can see it's
like a number essentially from like you
know none is zero but from one to like
14 and this basically just says this is
what type I am and will mean that in the
future because we need to be able to
kind of tell which type an event is and
you know we don't really don't want to
use something like dynamic cast or
runtime type information for something
as trivial as this it's easier just to
have an int ID kind of associated with
everything and then we can deal with it
okay so event categories the reason we
have these is because we basically may
want to filter certain events so in
other words I am receiving all events
from my application into some kind of an
event class but I only care about the
keyboard events right or free like
here's a really simple scenario I would
like to log every keyboard event now or
every mouse event let's say Mouse event
because there's more of them right so do
I really have to go and check to see if
the event type is pressed or released or
moved or scrolled that's a little bit
annoying so instead what I can do is I
can just say hey you know what just give
me all of the Mouse events and because
we have kind of this some event category
enum we're able to do that because it's
kind of like a it's almost like a um a
trait I guess that's applied to certain
event types so that we can actually see
what they are now this is a bit a bit
field essentially um if we just go to
this because I've just kind of defined
it in the cord or H file this is all it
is right define bit X as just one
shifted by X places
this just says that if you do a bit one
for example you'll have essentially just
a bit at position you know 1 0 would be
position 0 and so on and so forth so
that we can actually end up with a bit
of field right and the reason we want
that specifically in not just 0 1 2 3 4
is because we have the ability for an
event to go into multiple categories so
for example you know keyboard mouse and
mouse button events are all input events
a mouse button event is a mouse event
right a keyboard event is a keyboard and
an input event so we have kind of we
want to apply multiple categories to a
single event type so we need to create a
bit field so that we're gonna have
multiple bits set and then we can simply
just mask them out and see what what
kind of category and event or what
categories an event actually belongs to
during worried about these macros for a
second we'll get to them let's just take
a look at this actual event class okay
so first of all I just want to give a
quick pause you see how how nice this is
like it is my first time doing a video
in this format but imagine if I had to
write out all this code this video would
be like an hour long so I think that
this is actually a lot better and I
might not even have mentioned a lot of
the stuff I did just because I would be
you know stretched for time so um yeah I
just wanted to make a quick comment that
I'm actually enjoying this okay anyway
so we have this event class which will
talk about the event dispatcher later as
well but essentially this is a base
class for events the other thing this
actually stores is they handle the
bullying because we need to be able to
see if an event has been handled a lot
the reason we have that is because
further down the line when we actually
start to dispatch events to do various
layers for example it's pretty common
for us to decide to say that I don't
want this to be propagated any further
so a mouse click event for example if we
have a button on our screen and we've
clicked the mouse and the the mouse has
fallen within the bounds of the button
then that's it that event has kind of
been handled we want it to consume that
event so that the layer underneath it
which might be our game world doesn't
actually receive a click event because
of course it's already been handled by
the button so that's why we need this
here and of course in the future when we
actually get around
this you'll see real examples of this in
use is in Category is a very simple kind
of utility function which basically just
asks hey you know is this you know is
this kind of is this event for example
you know a mouse event or whatever is it
in the given category and we can just
use this quickly to filter out certain
events and all it does is just an end
with the actual category to see if it
actually belongs to that category or not
of course this will if this returns zero
it means that it's not in the category
at all if it returns anything other than
zero it will be caught it'll be true
right which means that it is at least in
that category might be in other
categories as well but it's at least in
this one then we have a bunch of virtual
functions some of them being pure
virtual which means they must be
implemented so such as get event type
get name get category flags now I
haven't decided whether or not I
actually want category flags to be a
debug or anything name definitely
probably like will be it's probably not
the biggest overhead to have but still
we because it's just a constant reminder
so it'll be like a pointer to constant
you know kind of read-only memory anyway
but mmm something to think about at the
moment I've left it obviously enabled
for all configurations but it's this
should really only be is for debugging I
don't I don't expect ever being having
the necessity to actually retrieve an
event name so yes but anyway that pure
virtual which means every event has to
implement them to string by default just
returns the name of the event obviously
if you have more details that you want
to be able to print such as you know
monitor let's go to a random event a
window resize event you might want to
print you know width and height like
I've done here then you can override
that to string function and actually say
that okay this is a window resize event
and I'm including this information with
it okay because I've kind of you know
this the to string is definitely a
debugging only thing I haven't been
really kind of attentive to performance
or anything like that i'm just using
string stream here not that the string
stream is terrible for performance but
obviously it has the ability to allocate
memory but again we don't care about
performance here at all because all this
is is a debug
kind of a print the event information
because I'm not sure my events are
working correctly or whatever right
should never be used by actual game
runtime for anything other than
debugging okay cool
moving on yeah so these have to be
implemented this by default you know it
the event class provides you with just a
default kind of to string which is just
the name of the event but of course you
have the ability to override that that's
it that's the whole event class so
before we get into the dispatcher let's
just actually look at what an event
might look like so I think I might um
maybe like a key event would be
something better to look at so a key
event is very simple obviously key
events work when we kind of press things
on our keyboard so if I press a key on
my keyboard that's a key press event
when I release the key from my keyboard
that's a key released event now these
these key events have certain things in
common right namely the key code of what
has been pressed or released right
whether it's press or released that's
should be its own event type
but the key code is common between those
events which is why I've made a base
class called key event which contains
the key code now key released probably
shouldn't need anything else apart from
just the fact that it's a key released
event therefore the key has been
released but a key pressed should also
have whether or not the key is a
repeated event what that means is that
when I press a key what happens usually
depending on the operating system and
the drivers and all that but usually
when I press a key it sends the
operating system sends a key pressed
event right and then waits like a little
bit and then it sends a bunch of key
repeat events you can see this in action
if I just kind of click somewhere and I
press the a key you'll see that there's
going and I'm gonna press and hold the a
key in a minute here you'll see there's
like it'll add the letter a will appear
immediately then there'll be a pause and
then it will print a bunch of them right
so yeah again a and then they're there
the rest right so the first one is a key
press event and then there's other ones
are essentially key repeat events so we
want to be able to kind of also
take that so that's how a press event
might be different from a released event
other than the name but because they
have that key code in common what I've
actually done here is I've created this
kind of key event base class as you can
see which just contains a key code
that's it it's also got a protected
constructor because nothing else can
construct it and then it's got it just
together for that key code obviously we
don't need to set the key code because
that happens when the event gets
constructed but we do want to get it and
then we have a macro which implements
this class category thing we will talk
about the macros in a minute because
there's more okay so a key pressed event
so essentially this is kind of like an
abstract event you shouldn't really be
able to make a key event you really
can't I mean it's got a protected
constructor so you won't be able to make
this class in anything other than a
class that derives from it so keypress
event is an actual event right that
we'll see in our engine it's basically
got a key code and a repeat count so I
haven't really decided whether or not we
want to keep track of the amount of
times that a key has been repeated
usually like essentially like this could
act like a boolean so you know I mean if
this is zero then it has not been it's
not a repeat event it's the first time
that Keys been pressed
but then the kind of remaining like if
it's anything other than when other than
the zero which might be one if it's been
repeated all like twenty if it's been
repeated twenty times or it could just
be one even if it has been repeated
twenty times depending on how we
implement it that just means it's a
repeat event so that's really like this
whole key repeat event stuff is really
really useful because if you know if
you're making something like a menu in
again so you have like four options in
your menu and the mouse isn't in use for
example you just want to use the arrow
keys to go down the menu obviously like
you know for as an example you might
want to only you might want to force the
user to actually press the arrow key
multiple times to go through something
instead of being able to press and hold
it traditionally if you just handle a
pressed event and you say that until
it's released go cycle through the menu
options that'll keep looping really
quickly and even if the user presses the
cake quickly it might actually still
send two events that's bad because the
way that this is set up is as you saw
with me typing
Anke it will kind of just send the event
wait a bit and then send a bunch of
repeat events because that's how most of
racism's handle this you could just you
don't you don't even need to worry about
repeat count for menus because you could
just say that you know obviously there's
that gap so you can just kind of you can
just kind of wait naturally until it
kind of that will give the user man
enough time to release it if they don't
want to go through multiple menu options
and then essentially you could just say
that I'll just let it naturally work
which means that you use the president
down or it goes down weights a bit and
there goes bumble the mobile all the way
down and maybe loops or whatever so
that's just a use case scenario anyway
um that's kind of the idea with repeats
we've implemented a two string function
here which overrides our two string and
just essentially says that this will
just print which queue has been pressed
and also the amount of times and then we
have this event class type macro which
implements all of our functions so let's
talk about these macros now we have
event class category and event class
type the reason these exist is because
we need these three things implemented
now event type name and category flags
are so trivial that I mean we don't
really need them now category flags
obviously does need the category to be
specified but name an event type I mean
the name is the event type and it's just
a pain to kind of type all this so
instead of us having to type essentially
all of this code I would I'll show you
what it wouldn't look like forgot a key
event you know if I wanted to employ
this stuff I'd have to basically say I
mean look at all this stuff we also need
a static type which we'll talk about in
a minute
but basically what I would need to say
is that I would need a static function
which returns the type of this event now
this is a key pressed event which if we
go to our event class it's this key
pressed event which would just be event
type key pressed I need to have a
virtual function which returns this
static type and we'll see why we need
that in a minute
um and then I wouldn't need this name
which again would probably be something
like that so instead of copying and
pasting this code in every single
implementer
I've just implemented a macro that I can
use which just says event class type and
then key press which is this type and
that's it and then obviously what it
will do is fill in the blanks it will
stringify it for the name and I mean
that's about it so that being said what
is the idea with these static types why
do we need them well
we want to be able to at runtime check
to see which type this key pressed event
is right so obviously we need a function
that returns which event type it is now
this does not have to be a member
function it can just be a static
function because if we say key pressed
event type or whatever we don't need to
have an instance of the key pressed
event class to actually see what type it
is obviously key pressed event is always
going to be a key pressed event no
matter what the instance is now the
reason we need a non instance based one
is specifically a virtual one right this
overrides a virtual function the reason
we need that is because if we just have
an event base class right if we're just
treating it kind of this is like a
polymorphic kind of thing we're just we
just have a reference or a pointer to an
event we want to be able to see what
type it actually is so we can do event
you know get event type and it will
return which event type it actually is
one implementation scenario for this is
the actual event dispatcher you can see
what it does here in the dispatch
function is it checks to see which event
type the current event that we're trying
to dispatch is whether or not it matches
this template argument and because this
is a static function we can just do take
call and call and get static type now
there's no type safety here to make sure
it's an event for example but it can
already have but that aside you can see
that obviously uh because it's just one
compile if this is an event or anything
that has get static type but anyway you
can see here we're able to do this
comparison between an event reference
which is just which could be any event
and this template argument and then if
server example in this case this
dispatchable dispatch it to the
appropriate event or to the appropriate
function essentially and we'll talk
about the event dispatcher in more
detail a little bit later but anyway
that's why we need these two
and then the get name you know just
returns the name for usually for
debugging purposes so all these three
are easily implemented with this one
macro same with the event class category
instead of us kind of having to you know
type out you know virtually and get
category flags constant override
whatever we can easily just say event
class category these two okay I've
ordered them together because of course
a keyboard event is also an important
event okay
and I've implemented this in the base
class because a key press and release
event are both of these anyway so I
don't need to implement them in their
own kind of classes okay that's the key
pressed event key release event is
identical except Issa's and does not
have that repeat count and obviously
it's just got a key released event and
the type is key released instead of key
pressed okay that is that is the Kalyan
now Mouse events exactly the same I mean
you guys probably already understand how
to write these a mouse moved event okay
is an event it's got x and y which is
the location of the mouse as it
currently stands
we've got getters for that we've got a
two string which prints mouse moved
event along with the coordinates and
then we will we've implemented these two
things which implement the mouse moves
class type which gives us all of our
type information and then also the event
class category which tells us which
kappa rates and that's it and then we're
storing everything you quick note for
the hazel kind of engine the coding
style that I've kind of adopted is
public stuff first and then private
stuff the reason is when you kind of
look at a class and you know you let's
just say you're running a game with the
heads London and you want to quickly see
what you can actually do with the API
obviously you don't care about the
implementation details which are private
right what you want to see first is what
you can actually use right so that's why
it makes more sense to me to just say
all the public stuff gets written first
and then the private kind of stuff that
is only in that is only kind of
interesting to us as developers as days
people developing the hazel engine you
know that's kind of let's just not talk
about that because if we're actually
using the hazel engine we want to
actually see what we can use and not
implementation details which we don't
care about
okay scroll event exactly the same right
we have our offset which is essentially
where we've kind of scrolled both x and
y because there is horizontal scrolling
that we can do on some mice and then
this obviously prints all of the
information implements all the type
stuff as well but an event again you
know this is an actual base class and
then we have button press button
released we have our button being stored
here this is protected so that we can't
create this event only the mouse button
pressed event and release event can
create that and then we have everything
else implemented kind of as usual you
get the drift application event has
things like window resize window close
event window close event is really
simple has absolutely nothing it's in
the application event category and all
it really is is just hey I'm a window
close event it doesn't need any data at
all resize event has the width and
height that we've been resized to and
then we have also these four events
which I'm not sure if I'm going to use
yet but we have ticket an update event
and render event this is if we would
like our kind of you know update render
and tick functions to actually be
propagated as events which is doable but
again if we were trying to be really
like pedantic about our correct kind of
event system usage then maybe everything
should be an event and thus you know
thus we should have this implemented as
an event but because they're kind of you
know sorry so intrinsic to an actual
application I feel that maybe this
should just be hard-coded that's just
like you know these three are like you
know actual non-modular events they're
always present and you can choose to
implement them or you don't have to but
they're kind of already there for you
you don't need to first receive them as
an event and then dispatch them to a
function there already called and I'm
I'm leaning towards doing it that way
but just in case we do have these three
events over here okay so that is that
that's what I've actually added these
kind of four four files which are
for your full event system are the
dispatcher let's quickly talk about that
so the dispatcher is a is a way for us
to actually dispatch events based on
their type really easily okay so if
we're if we receive an event and we you
know our own event function gets called
we will we will be receiving it as an
event reference which means that it
could be any type of event we have no
idea what it is so what we can do is we
can actually write we can create an
instance of this class with the event
that we've just received and then we can
call this dispatch function a bunch of
times with with a different event
function and this event function is as
you can see it's an it's a standard
function all right which returns bull
and takes in T reference so T in this
case could be any event type like window
resize event so we could say bull
dispatch in a window resize event and
then we could implement a function
somewhere in our engine usually in the
same class as you've actually are
handling is this event in but
essentially a function that takes in you
know a window resize event and then
returns a boolean and then uses
basically passes through and if the
event that you're trying to dispatch
matches the type of this function
essentially then it will actually run
that function it'll call that function
with that event otherwise it just won't
right that's really it it's really easy
to use we'll see it in action probably
in the future when we actually start you
know receiving events from like the
window class or whatever but that's kind
of just a really easy way for us to
actually be able to not have to say you
know manually now on event function if
the event type is key event called the
key pressed you know on key pressed
function with the in your and also cast
this to it you know to the to a key
pressed event because it's currently
just a normal base event this kind of
automates that it makes our code in the
client side look really simple and then
finally we have a little output stream
operator this exists for our logging
library so that we can easily just call
to string on the event
and we'll be able to log events really
easily as we'll see in a minute okay
that's all of the new files that I've
added I'm going to take you through the
diff of the kind of existing files that
I've modified I've set up a very very
simple example of a surveillance system
feel free to just play around with it
and make your own examples or just you
know play just play around with it so
that you can understand how it works a
little bit better
obviously as we add like a window class
and we actually start receiving these
real events like real input events will
be heavily using this system but for now
it's kind of just there for us to use so
yeah let's just take a look at all the
dips so I'm using beyond compare here
I've really just run gift.if tool and
I've set up the on compare as my dev
tool I've done a full directory diff so
this is everything that's changed so
let's take a look so if you think a few
things that I did in the pre-made file
is from last episode you might you might
have realized add a little I added a
little note this wasn't in the last
episode this was in the Premack episode
but I added a little note saying that we
don't actually have to hard code this
there is a system version latest now in
przemek that we can just use and our
just use the latest system version so
that's what we want so I've changed that
for both the sandbox and the hazal
projects and then I've also added into
it the include directories for hazel
I've also added the source directory
this is just so that we can you know do
stuff like because you know this event
is inside the events folder this event
on edge file but I don't really want to
go back a directory and go into core or
whatever I want to be able to just start
from the source directory and always do
my parts kind of relative to that source
directory which contains Hazel's so if
we look at what all files here you can
see we have a source directory and the
fact that I've added this source
directory here means that everything is
about everything can be relative to this
which means I can just write hazel call
like that and it's really clean it also
means that if this file moves into a
different folder I don't have to redo
all my paths everything's going to be
always relative to this okay so that's
all the changes that I made to the pre
make file obviously I have ran the
generate project's batch file and I've
actually regenerated all of these
projects which means that that's why
these two have changed
so yeah okay application so I've
included events here probably didn't
need to do it necessarily in the
application file in the header file
could be done in the CPP file but all
I've really done here is just and we'll
run this code in a minute
but I've just created a little test I've
created a window resize event like that
and then I've just logged it using H set
trace and because we've added those
output stream operators we should just
be able to do that okay cool
and then in quarter H I added that bit
macro just so that we can define bit
fields easily and then into our logging
system I have added this include which
is the output stream operator for SPE
low for speed log so that we can
actually use our kind of custom so that
we can log custom types like in our
events okay that's it that's all that's
changed so to do a little test here what
I've done is again I've got this window
resize event just creates a window
resize event and then we just love it if
I run this code you can see that I get
my window resize event being logged
correctly and everything is great if I
do something else you know why couldn't
for example say you know is this in the
is in category but in our application
then we could trace it otherwise you
know if it's in let's just write
category that is not in event plus event
category input so this should only log
it once right and I can put a breakpoint
here just to verify what actually
happens you can see it is in that
category so we actually log it and it's
not in this category so we skip it and
in the end it gets logged once ok so
that's kind of the idea it's really
quite simple
and we've got a very basic test
obviously as we start to implement a
window class which is probably gonna be
our next major thing after maybe some
other things like precompiled headers
will actually start using this event
system properly and you'll see it fully
in action all right so I hope you guys
enjoyed this video let me know what you
think of this new format I really like
it this ended up
over 30 minutes anyway imagine if I'd
written all this code it were probably
an hour I probably be really boring and
I'm just I'm really happy and it this
just makes it easier for me as well
because instead of concentrating and
making sure that I'm not forgetting
anything and typing the right code again
I'm less stressed about that and I'm
actually I can actually spend more time
explaining what the card actually does
and like to me that's more fun and
possibly more useful to you guys let me
know if you notice any differences in
kind of how this goes and the
information you're getting out of this
anyway I hope you guys enjoy this video
if you didn't hit that like button you
have support this series by going to
patron Ocampo slash the channel as I
said earlier you will get access to that
private repository in which we already
have a window class I just hit the
microphone I'm sorry in which we already
have the window class as well as all
these events being used so you want to
see this event system in action like
today you can just go and help support
the series and of what obviously does
help actually support this series so
you'll see more episodes and it's just a
good little community we have which
makes this series possible which is
awesome because I love making these
videos for you guys next time I really
want to do precompiled headers and then
after that I think we'll probably
finally be able to start talking about
how we can implement a window class
because getting something on the screen
would be quite nice I'm really happy we
have this advanced system one thing that
I just remembered that I didn't talk
about is and it which will probably be
more or less tied with the winter class
is going to be an input system so we
have the ability to be notified about
input events but we can't actually ask
as to what the current state of like a
key on our keyboard is that's going to
be important as well because whilst
receiving events are great it's also
really nice to be able to say hey you
know it is the left mouse button
currently pressed we can't actually do
this with the system what we could do is
receive a mouse event and then store
that event until we get a mouse released
event and in that way you know we could
save mouse buttons press but instead of
doing that on the client side I'd like
to move that into hazel and just have it
as something that the API can do so we
will kind of revisit input events in the
future to support that but again that's
not an advances
thing that's just a that's just like an
input state input manager conflate
anyway hope you guys enjoy this video I
will see you next time goodbye
[Music]